were so fool we're so cool podcast we're
here with Rodrigo Torres yeah man what's
happening I guess right here Jorge Perez
or sighting Eddie from the Jorge Perez
stories Lisa right here chillin right
here with her blanket we're gonna have a
good time man Aryan they just got back
from the Halawa Halloween extravaganza
lasted two weeks extra bouquet I was up
for the first one bro retail I went long
just trying to do it yourselfers like a
baby game man
yeah now usually when you have a dating
game you know you work your way up to be
nasty it's grown a stir in the first
question how was the house I know I was
the right away you know no surprises and
she's like a junior varsity porn star
like she hasn't even done a junior B's
bro Arby's yeah like she's I don't know
man I'm out I don't hate but she was
we're dog who are well people dressed up
though how was a party though we didn't
dress up dog but how was the there was a
lot there was a lot of people dressed up
it mean it was a good crowd good
environment well they sold out
I brought a homeboy that went crazy dog
he Bali he probably bought like 50 and
aquila dog it was this Mexican food that
looks Samoan so everybody was scared
yeah he looks like he's in booyah tribe
dog and he just bought tequila shot up
the tequila shot for everybody so my
team was able me the bargain costume
contest
I don't need they even had it now people
win a costume just because they said
like Mario went in the costume Megaman
that's crazy man when a park a litter is
that to fly out he fired a drive out fly
out laughter with mega man bro I want to
stay with that guy they pay me yeah boys
over you man record you sleeping in two
days he stayed with them yeah what
happened with you and Apple was that old
or what it was is he talk some [ __ ] dawg
and about what you got mad dawg what's
he gonna talk [ __ ] about he got mad at
some [ __ ] dog and I clowned on him and
he's like dog you said you backstab me
for Magon on me for that [ __ ] dawg mega
man you told me was a listener first
like stealing come on man but Amy
everything was when the mayor laid when
I got there monkey with you gotta make a
video cuz everyone thinks you're gonna
kill this guy
hey Mario was like a dog don't knock
this floor I don't want to carry him
like to the house I gotta stay with the
dog but he was cool dog he was just a
little drunk belligerent they got him
high again dog and it was over they had
him hosting the show interviewing people
dog with the hurt be on his lip on a fog
dog get a mega man hurt yeah bro we I
interviewed his hurt beat and then Mario
brought some full dog I almost beat him
up I felt bad those guys that like he
was trying to tell me how do I get a
homie you should be promoting yourself
different dog like you should be doing
this you know everything yeah yeah and I
was just like my babies you guys are
formulas yeah [ __ ] I got to the point
dog where I was like hey homie we're
gonna fight if you don't leave ya came
up to me go get this fool the [ __ ] out
of your dog but you know you're gonna
see a lot of people walk up to you now
that's just one they're all starting
with one blood and then after that man
listen man I think they own a piece of
the show yeah
he'd even come or not herpes I don't
know how do you blow up people America
they don't take out their know they're
out there jokbal I love to do comedy
time for you to leave join and I don't
want you the teacher the tic-tac-toe at
Riga Jews I do all the new Latinos hit
you up and sure I can imagine your
dancer just say Philippe Eiffel boy
hides to I have a fresh five a hot in I
[ __ ] around like if I'm in a great mood
that do you know I'm gonna put you up
dog hey I put him up at the Brea improv
it was a home ad and sell it out I fly
heard it now I ain't gonna [ __ ] like
that little fact it was to the brims
that fool Brody Stephens was like good
luck man yeah first time red bands like
my first time was in front of 12
yeah hey dog you know how it is homeboy
went up there thinking he was gonna
murder - huh he was a comic Street free
dog if you wanna go yeah I'm gonna go -
you give yourself wolf on a stage
there's a but now but when people say
they want to do like comedy like I want
to try on like man it's [ __ ] hard bro
today is easy we could we goof off up
there man
people think your way if you see
somebody looking slay you think it's
easy because go back do it what is that
white could mean the real well talking
to people in the audience and he bags
hard he from Canada oh that fool you bet
him bad he's good see ya people see him
and I didn't chicken I've just jump in
his be like that on stage bro no bro you
don't have a [ __ ] joke to back it up
bags ready years of stuff in catalog in
his brain you remember that one time
[ __ ] uh he was warming up for the gay
locals taping and Betty man I was in
front row no what do you do for a living
man I do comedy that's where the Laugh
Factory has Felipe never heard of it
they opened up a weird San Diego and you
know the madhouse comedy chromoly move
that [ __ ] no way they're in a
corner around the Bergen comedy club oh
well like an L way from fool and guess
what I found out before I left you know
tower stain and guess who move what
comedy club is moving into that basement
and they don't they're gonna have a
tower 90 room comedy club like comedy
plows Laugh Factory
Wow yeah so then I have three common
criminals seems a common dude like like
New York almost like cut madhouse with
150 company Laugh Factory with a hundred
maybe ninety and then I'm the other
piece of [ __ ] comedy club with [ __ ]
the order to [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] that yeah
that is 250 yeah I'm tired
uncomfortable 250 by the way yeah Carl
oh yeah that's great you know it's a
good idea dog we told him that I I'm
ahead of my time
Chiba right here brother George Perez
back for Cleveland bro yeah that was
Joey did he's dude he made it was you to
lose our eating huh now a home visit
with you yeah I think what to that uh
that chocolate bar right there where we
stayed at the arcade
now we went to the hotel that that's an
old ass place [ __ ] yeah ain't homey no
school you know you're staying that then
a whole area and for a Christmas story
yeah hey homie it's old casino there you
can lose all the money you made yeah
yeah the casinos like two blocks to your
right and then we also went to the strip
club Christie's that should be yeah bad
data they had a Russian guy at the door
and I told that people know it strip
club I work in they know each of the
owners I even verified it with my owner
so they gave me a little love dog dog I
can't say that no the owner of Christie
though declare met at one time we were
he would kind of I don't remember he's
from Memphis Tennessee he from the same
era of Elvis and he would tell me that
because you know when Elvis died and I
was dad was still alive right there's a
top yes you're talking about that's
badass place we're now so the gamma they
get me sure the cat one time with he
would leave in Christie's and we're in
the same area and then we got him a
thing he told he was out of that I was
pressed they will go to Christie's over
there were in Memphis like it do they
have an over there he go he will call up
into a reserve a table for the king yeah
he will tell you that they gave me
what's the name of the colonel lady
they're gonna play the piano
the singer Jerry Lee Lewis
that fool he told her that that would do
gigs
he's already old like he was like 70 and
some moonshine out of his car there on
the show when he was young hey buy
alcohol they bought that [ __ ] it was a
it is cousin right hey Christian I made
the mistake of going with fans dog cuz
you know I'm scared of high stupid room
yeah I'm scared of heights dog and I
don't want to drive over the bridge and
withhold money from not but walkie
hey and then a home like this [ __ ] is
trying to get Eve she caught her man
cheese look look at his cell phone
there's girls texting him and I was like
what the [ __ ] I don't know I was just
like let's go get a half hour at this
girl on my way home girl you're tripping
and then this is gonna half hour well a
half hour is is like when the girl does
things to me and things to her and then
like what was that cost 250 she went
right there yeah yeah in my head I would
have told her about it but then I said
no and then that fool was like yo dawg
we're gonna ditch my wife right now so
they were both playing you to get back
at the other happy although I took them
back to my room dawg oh yeah but I made
him Jam cuz he lied yeah they were like
we're gonna go buy beer we're gonna go
get some weed and I was like so what's
up put the beer in the weed oh it's too
late I'll just like well I gotta go to
sleep but it was a Chrissy was cool dog
they had you been there and they got
those two they got the pole I've never
been there I don't think I'm gonna wanna
strip or walk out of the order go in the
cab we were sharing the cab okay but the
day owner he looked like they could [ __ ]
somebody up like he would he do they
belong in the Allman Brothers I'm out
here [ __ ] tall blue like Big John
Studd oh [ __ ] Mikey
yeah and he was old he was one of the
old guys but I don't know who was it now
buddy buddy was telling me cause he gave
me a man gave me his car cause you ever
got any Christian let me know me
I know all of them yeah it was a dog it
was a [ __ ] that's my thing every city I
go to I go to the strip club because I
want to see the competition and how
they're doing [ __ ] except San Jose it
was Gay Pride Week oh yeah we make
bottle like all the other Latinas who
live in the surrounding areas go there
because there ain't Dana no I mean it's
just see a place like Cleveland's old
school so it was more classy they don't
let fat girls another I like to grow the
clubs where the girls a little bit
normal cuz they'll let you do [ __ ] Nick
was on an arm no Nicholas is like that's
that's bad you go to clubs where they
discriminate on the weak
yeah no I go to clubs where it's like
the girls are like 29 they're a little
more desperate yeah baby baby we can we
that's gonna strip bar we you look at
the stripper going man this [ __ ] should
be here bartending when they like pale
do they got they got Four Seasons not
homey it was cool because like I haven't
seen pretty ones in a long time like you
know what I mean
like they were class you know they were
number than that party tooth huh when I
was there we the first time we went that
we stood at the we did the Cleveland
improv so we're like I'm here with and
then we have to go down the hill over
the bridge
make sure the projects oh and we were
walking through the projects I think Joe
other black projects oh yeah these are
senior hog grew up there
yeah that's his hood where he grew up
that's a the neighborhood was down there
and this food got stuck in the comedy
condo because they have a comedy condo
bro that [ __ ] she had no food
everything far but nothing brothers no
store on there's no supermarket nothing
just a bar and Christie's she knows yeah
a little alley just to building and
there's something selling hot dogs
outside yeah that's what the condo is no
way I'd be in trouble there's no strip
club that one time and there wasn't
anybody to look at in there dog it was a
strip club in Peoria looking girls I did
it I did a show I think it was [ __ ]
where's that place in the middle of
going to the bay and they got a
Spearmint Rhino there Santa Maria Santa
Maria back in the days and I did it was
the mondo co-ceo uh-huh across the
street with a hustler yeah I remember
the hustler but oh it was a spirit they
might have been changed
no the spirit back then it was good a
home no doing the show like the I went
over there and everybody smoked me out
and now I think everybody else had a
good time but we like we left the show
to go hang out over there are the
comedian's going up too long the
appreciate of being there man there were
the cheetah more like they act the
cheetah does away with the military does
like real nice yes since we worked in a
strip club
I know exactly what to say to this girl
you know what does you what went on was
something want me to play no you can't
do that well you just go to the hey my
girlfriend left me I'm sad man I got
like 250 a ting time right there CA my
right dog normally you going what do
they know that light already
hey homie there's a ghetto-ass cloak
called flamingo it got shut down the
roaches got staph they had all they had
a handshake named that dog in Anaheim
Anaheim off ball and [ __ ] but dog it was
the call the flamingo handshake because
when you go in there the girls come up
to you and grab your dick saying hello
yeah I'm doing value but this shitty a
stripper one of Van Nuys then Saticoy no
no no Roscoe and Sepulveda that please
to be a jacket Abbas bro oh right like
to a gas station like the jacket box now
across the street and the old Jack in a
bar is a strip bar it's called sin
xxx it's the one door and like the
chicks the stripper smokes cigarettes
outside and when people who are popping
guests to see oh my is sad but you know
what sometimes like I remember when I
would look up for if it's a girl
complaining I know it's a good one yeah
not a at the bird dog we wit one time in
the girls are like the bird
yes flamingo we call it the bird oh my
god a dirty bird and it's not it's not
you wanna dance yeah yeah they were like
I'm like I got 45 I got 25 man looked at
each other this is splitting no stop it
was crazy now the bird it's closed down
pretty dog and then the owner is like a
dirty Middle Eastern guy dog and he's
sitting on the stage by the tip rail
watching us the whole time dog well gee
Louis Peraino stripper I want time with
him will kill somebody bro yeah he was
pretty sure they're talking [ __ ] in like
in Lebanese Armenian yeah syndrome I
just brain is your coffee the Nestene a
little more of the gastro sweating
please you guys got a spray for roaches
what the kill one day knows something
about like [ __ ] that fool doing
something against his race and [ __ ] then
I walked in there although did you spray
on like like the carpeting grab they
were spraying you know I never see them
again
that full [ __ ] roll up in a mailbox
howdy [ __ ] [ __ ] around trip and smell
like ass still encounter like strippers
who are working there and then you spot
their boyfriend oh they're all mad spine
kick those losers I don't hate other
spine no more like they show in the car
no these other fools will come on a bike
I want to say that motorcycle Dhar like
I like they're like his destiny in their
BC yeah you got a memory dog like for
him he's kind of pimping her and he's
like eight she's gonna give him 20 bucks
and he's gonna go get drugs and he's
gonna take a hit then give it her and
that gets in exchange they do all the
car I walked the girl out cycle man and
I'm like where's you're right at home
boy [ __ ] pulls up with a drift
stopped on the back brake [ __ ] hops on
the pegs dog and takes off I think
they're very few strippers who do it
just because they want to do it oh yeah
and she had this young 26 year old in
there that she had hook and he would
just wait in the car and Heydar you not
only that too but there's the chick
that's been doing this to she was 18 and
I know this I think I met her 15 years
ago when I first started doing this [ __ ]
and then she's still dancing for the
club I work at and she does she's
married everything husband has a good
job she does it because she's addicted
to the life dog yeah like she like it I
don't care about making money I just
want to hang out here she lets us know
cigarettes and carpet yeah we had Jesse
and Andy these chicks are like 47 dog
making a thousand a day we're at a TJ
Club we're at and their husband's a
contractor that's in Japan
she finally moved them moved with them
but hey homie was crack but when he was
going to work for she would like did he
did he no no because she would get gifts
like [ __ ] iPads no more these
customers would bring in gifts for them
and she's like I can't take this [ __ ]
home to my husband I don't know I'm
dancing again so he's like I got a
hundred I got 150
we're just bidding on that [ __ ] that's
how you met her man you know what Lisa
is like since they don't have a
boyfriend at home they cook for us
sometimes they like hey guys
oh me oh me soulless [ __ ] was cooking
laughter oh and no song when she cooks
talk she pays attention there every
season and she puts in there there's a
killer meatloaf a shepherd's pie all the
pots and pans right and I saw the pan
and you know oh no Stig pans but
everything stuck at the bottom of the
[ __ ] pan loo like iron rod is peeling
off I said I don't know where was daddy
yeah I gotta be like Nina Brown at the
crack shop dog yeah well also put an egg
in Newberry stuck just keep it off
tortilla pop the yokel rixel make a mess
here all [ __ ] storm what's up ooh I like
the large stop going to strip bars and
MIT will be timbrel oh I've been to one
in Wilmington it's called a bunch of
okay if you don't know it looks do walk
your dog ah but it's my fellow tenants
Western hey I seen that one for this
full rope his radio and his babies my
kick came across the mouth she put buy
diapers
you can't even go you can even go live
anymore bro you can't be a look at me
you can be like a figure in Instagram or
a figure in part care like somebody who
knows you I gotta keep mentioning you
like Mega Man or Alex the large or who
[ __ ] Greg Riley for San Diego
you can't them once you go people to
mention your podcast then you go live
and your friends start noticing you all
Phillippi will sleep as parson now you
were drugged perez then the real friends
come in and go [ __ ] you know the piece
of [ __ ] yeah the piece of [ __ ] maybe
with my diaper for kids [ __ ] leave me
on a baby [ __ ] homie I had a fan tell me
that deny your dog your baby's mom says
you're a horrible death I said in the
corner of look [ __ ] I only have to pay
a hundred and eighty bucks a month day
I'm [ __ ] a good dad I was a bad daddy
to be 300 that means the lady's talking
[ __ ] cuz I got emails about a couple of
the listeners who are how happy she was
like talking [ __ ] about Mega Man baby
mama DM does after he did our episode
with him and not us we're just innocent
parties in all this right over here see
because she talks [ __ ] it will he talk
[ __ ] about her dog episode and she's
like [ __ ] therefore I'm not lazy you use
that though a [ __ ] lips it they played
the podcast the just subscribe dog you
gotta you probably the pocket coin like
you really like it yeah mega man verify
that [ __ ] yeah he says that uh lose
custody man no because uh they showed
the messages a you are on [ __ ] GPS
and you were talking all that [ __ ] about
me he's like I just want to see my
daughter and then she was like no I'm
using all this against you and
judges like a man like those 15 now
Fidel where they call it much of a piece
of [ __ ] as you think your dude your ex
dude is I don't understand wanting to
him to keep that person away from your
kid unless they're dry yeah if there's
no record of danger yeah that kid should
be with their father I don't understand
why women like just the hairy problem
with your baby mama or your baby daddy
and you start dating one of her friends
now and now they [ __ ] gonna lose any
years after they'd been broken up how
they met at the baby shower oh my god
that's happened to me where one of my
babies my look at the homie and he was
I'm sorry my what are you sorry about
Dawg you're helping out now so thanks to
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
welcome to the nuclear family yeah well
my first baby's mom's has seven babies
dancing yeah I'm just happy none of them
are my enemies and gangbang yeah but I
have the first kid from her oh [ __ ] you
cited the flag
yeah I'll never get I'll never get child
support because all her kids are
outsourcing now he gets like a 3-bedroom
for like 60 bucks
homie she she gets homeless people to
help her move [ __ ] in the family that
should sleep in her way to the bottom
bro yeah she was like a [ __ ] wuss
lowest Everest kids from seven
basketball players off producing movies
bro yeah but she do she face as she gets
all the kids took from her every time
they take when she makes an on one
because that's the only way she could
stay on it that's like a movie like when
you die you come back to life she's
played but she's playing the pain like
what kid am I gonna keep
movie I watched it sound like baby baby
daddy two baby boys man with that stuff
- what baby daddy was tyree with yo lady
how you have a boy watching that movie
but mad don't everything is moving into
the [ __ ] car yeah I took her car and
kicked it with you time yeah that was
when we met
yeah that was like the same a few days
that we met yeah it was the car that's
the best chilaquiles ever had a Felipe
treating me like he bought me the night
before oh good I'm thinking about your
pan wasn't that great dog show W just
house only we looking at here it scared
my ladies car we stole this in the back
in his spot so we from zombies how'd you
beat up George that's a strip club dog
but before that what we doing oh yeah oh
no she pretty much is damn near [ __ ] she
goes on more than me but not da was
drafted out of high school into the
strip club at 18 so I've been dumb 32
now I'ma be 33 in April's I've been in
this [ __ ] [ __ ] too long right out of
school like they win they win to the
high school like alright this guy is
gonna be the next manager of the strip
club we're going to put it from Taemin
to him but now I mean it was interesting
being young because when you're working
there you're making money you're young
like any [ __ ] yeah she's like [ __ ]
College I don't need College right now
but I should have went to college has
two kids from a stripper one strippers
sucking one most time fools give one
with one in their stock but I [ __ ]
what it was is I got her pregnant I like
look man you ain't dancing her stripping
no more all my friends work they'll bag
on me that's what you think
yeah you know what I did it was like a
creative player when I made a drug dog I
took it to the dental school got a
little dental assistant license got her
out of the game all that [ __ ] dog so it
was like you know I'm more like that you
know I'm older I'm also a mom and [ __ ]
but I was with her for a while and I was
like I won't do that to a woman
no they won't put the time and effort
into it no more like in the Honda like
96 with no motor in it dog you got to do
all the work get it back together tell
her tell her her life's meaningful you
know stuff like that get a bracelet no
she had nice teeth thankfully so this
bull started working with me dog and
like right away me and him were like
feed my dog he's a wolf so but that's
what cook might be too I guess we've got
sweet and then like a year later after
meeting them I go hey homie I'm gonna
start a podcast like in a year you're
gonna be my co-host and he was this like
what the [ __ ] what's a podcast yeah
what's a podcast yeah more drugs on you
or not let's do some more and then we
started going out I don't know where
he's like hey burn way that [ __ ] I told
you we're gonna start all right we're
starting at this Tuesday I'm like all
right [ __ ] yeah and what you start doing
them in the strip club when you first
started working there I everyone starts
at the door dog except this fool because
they knew he was a comedian dog security
one door top always been primetime oh
[ __ ] yeah like yeah the tips the DJ gets
10% goes triple independent country I
just found this inside [ __ ] recently
licking this [ __ ] down where they can
benefit on linking it dog can alright I
gonna say on this saying there's a new
law passed in January were shit's gonna
be crazy now new device no they can
never billion no because they start
being paid dog oh I know be like they're
gonna mow
yeah salary they're late cost hairstyle
like a waiter independent contractor you
get socks tab punch that's not our
problem as your plaza happen to you
whatever they don't rent watch what
they're doing is the rent in the club
the reigning security they're renting us
to make sure they get their money and
like the song so that's why the end of
the day the DJ will get 10% the floor
guy will get 5% and the door guy will
get 2% yeah the security guy will get
$10 to turn it back that's one you gotta
have someone on the floor that knows
what the [ __ ] yeah you got a sucker
there it's not gonna work
me and Eddie were killing a dog we make
sure the whole team the teammate you
know are there any strippers who don't
go the extra mile
oh hell yeah they just dancin leave
there's regular ones that like that so I
say good maybe 2% but that's not every
day Lisa like they're like that twice
out of the week
how's the hose yeah like if they got
money the night before they're not gonna
be every one of them at some point if
one girl is if one girl suckin dick at
that club it's gonna domino effect
because the competition you're gonna
notice it this we had this one ugly
chick dog
huggy making money dog and every
customer was in line wait give it up for
savage dog we're pretty buying tickets
like it's one of your cells dog yes
she's got Gordie Lee she was taking the
back door yeah who so no a group on a
Monday not on so everyone said you know
what we're doing it I'm doing it
boom you guys go so much I mean I know
you worked there too but you guys go or
you watch strippers so much does it
still do anything for you are you hoping
for the extra stripper yeah
for me is like working on material I go
in there bag on the girls like when I go
there but I'll throw like money on I'm
high are you going just kidding you know
[ __ ] like that for me it's always like
I'm you know it's like video games it's
like I [ __ ] I already passed all these
games there's a new game coming yeah
game stuff it's about the new for you
yeah and plus it's also the bar I go
after the bartender this foot works that
one that's 18 and over I work at a 21
over dog so there's 18 yards into a
turnover is more older been a bit oh my
that's what we play at work we pay
pedophile or I'll cover it up yeah hey I
see pools and look like Honest John in
there drug dog schoolteachers bullying
do that brother they go in there bro
they really they look [ __ ] like damn
you spend your money on this homie
they're in a wheelchair we got a for my
club we got a foot that has crutches for
the mathematician and he's to be an
actor dog hockey we got full like that
that's on crutches and he's he's to act
with Jim Carrey and all the Murray's in
the wringer yeah he's a dog and the
girls say is a big-ass dick hey I'm
gonna get a this fool comes in and he
comes in a little Lexus dog door coupe
dog yeah where he puts his arm crutches
a rails a dog and like he [ __ ]
forever to get in that door but once he
gets in he's waited and then we got this
nether fold as a scooter and he [ __ ]
runs over everybody everybody [ __ ] that
fool dog I [ __ ] he's kicking [ __ ]
hardest [ __ ] huh well what's crazy the
fools in the wheelchair we got to help
him out fool
Christmas echo bro
[Music]
the girls will give you a 30 bucks to
pick him back up yeah he fell on the
ground could he pick him up yeah I was
like what homeboys on the ground for
like a sea turtle or them soon no well
there's another old guy that gets
dropped off by his caregivers yeah they
drop them off at [ __ ] one and they
pick him up at six that's like pop I
think pops going over there and then
leaving his wallet no but there were
like no that's his family I go dude he's
white in there asian no what about the
time it was me you and pops and you guys
judged the stripper contest at that Club
and that full bottle of pizza yeah and
afterwards we went to that fools
apartment and then the strippers are
there my pops was just like waiting to
punch one and take a haul
he was a pop Pop's give me score he was
ripping the paper who sucks and I'm
horrible at this
he carved a [ __ ] in the table man what
you that guy man he got locked up who
together the butter the pizza mm George
and I think so yeah he came in with a
stack of money but just oh I know you're
talking about this van Tony Lema yeah he
got locked up for a party yeah for the
Ponzi scheme he got a lot of people how
many me tell you man you know this
comedian's comedian told me one time
once it was comedian broke my leg bugs
anyway so he therefore sent him a chick
to do everything man yeah he's told like
everything didn't even charge him so
he'll get people on [ __ ] yeah he was
trying to get me baby go get me buddy
gonna have $1 right yeah he got a he was
going to my strip clubs and then he
would just make making her he look for
Bobby and then he go eh George how much
money do I I gotta pay you to leave I go
I make like 400 and ankles here's 500
give honor to your manager I'm just like
[ __ ] yeah so we would take two strippers
with us and go to
cases and he would just hook it up and
like I noticed something weird all dog
cuz my homeboy back team he's not my
homeboy Lamar but Dylan was like yelled
I could get this for ten G's he gave me
back twenty two and three days I just
gave him twenty two I haven't talked to
him in three days I was just like well
you know what yeah I know where he lives
so he was just enough didn't get
chocolate because I'm always that movie
and part I don't know I guess but he got
locked up the first time I saw a fool I
was doing the Commerce Casino with Rudy
beretta and he came in there and there
was like four or five chicks right and
then it was three dudes or his
bodyguards and I knew them from gotham's
I'm sorry I only pick people that from
the area like I thought Tina whatever
you know recognizable people you know
that credit in there yeah so he [ __ ]
showed up I made like a big scene you
know Batta Batta sir at the show telling
everybody
Rudy all happy oh yeah he was a a don't
charge my bottle I'll take the money
works on American weed they promise you
big dividends but promise you big that
they promise you if I would give
somebody ten thousand dollars in three
days that will give you twenty five and
if I have a hundred I'm gonna agree to
anything over eight percent when you
watch American greed that that [ __ ] will
never work if the other person that
greedy to the other person who always
has Robin oh my [ __ ] that you want
you're right it's that old adage she
can't twenty you give me another 50 I
give you 20 and every time I could give
you letter you give me a hundred
thousand you ever see me a six-month
I'm gonna go I've never done shut up
[ __ ] da they got me too
they [ __ ] got me da da support that
[ __ ] that movie battle battle jingle
he trippin my boy that was bad bro it's
a big bad
I'm always horrible because Michael
Poggi back that the original Carlito the
way man when you watch it sail Eileen
Cupid somebody that was married to
homegirl from eggs that's [ __ ] Manolo
from Spartans Viggo Mortensen that's how
they do that's right
that's why fools get out of prison dog
like they give that full of deal they
get out go but get your iron yeah hey
but from the beginning of Carlito's Way
I knew that that [ __ ] was
against them that guy he was gonna shoot
that killing right now like switch sides
nasty at the end you said it but it's
darker than you they're gonna be let's
take him around the back like old times
power and we told them not to bring the
gang was it how about the man they don't
there are four times of drug dealer hard
that [ __ ] trans down on the beginning
he wanted the cred dog you want to walk
in there worker lead over and she'd kill
that [ __ ] how they sliced that
fool yeah that one for that kill him
look weird dog yeah that's worth he's a
comedian too
oh yeah you were the killer a ghost I
heard he was real good was right there
in the Charlie barne did it look like
skinny skinny Mark Anthony yeah host up
the Apollo - oh wow
back in the day papa what's up fool
upcoming shows Toledo Ohio this week in
November 8th through the 10th a bit of
funny bone in Toledo Ohio I never been
there before man so we don't know what's
gonna happen but a man if you live in
Canada and you want to come down to hook
you up Canada you mean Buffalo you mean
you come down here by Winnipeg Buffalo
New York Buffalo New York November 16
through the 18 we'll be at the helium
comedy club champion rizona December 7
through 9 the Tempe Arizona never lost a
bar there to Ontario California
Rick a belay that's right our chair of
California December 28th to the 30th
also December 31st New Year's Eve at the
Paramount Theater Denver Colorado check
out all the Philebus world.com slash
tour and get all the shows yeah what's
your email what's your Instagram
birthday like the Getty on Instagram all
war on the word put together you only
[ __ ] with it
yeah Instagram Twitter I try the dog and
it's hard to keep up with that [ __ ] dog
you can catch me at george p comedy
twitter instagram
november 30th I'm headlining the Bailey
room at the Comedy Store it's 10:30 show
and I got my bells came in this week I
don't know what's going on but I'll be
around how are you his dog putting them
choke holds let me get my 5% [ __ ] like
that dog [ __ ] tomorrow I got to do some
[ __ ] we got GPS tomorrow I'm gonna do
another show bro at the Comedy Store
I am I'm November 30th if you want to
come come but I was dangerous girl I
don't want that I mean I'm down to the
main room I'm down Iqaluit me yeah we
were talking about in the crisper drawer
Perez Christmas bells you down to do why
don't we just do our okay let's do it I
can make it a big show map for him in a
row you know it'll be us my team yeah we
put people in the show at The Comedy
Store they're not part yes yeah I'm done
thank you do with taco shop yeah hey
Dawg [ __ ] impact and the the next
November 30th HBO is gonna be their
first [ __ ] but I'm not really a showcase
now but I'm not trying to disrespect HBO
but I'm not gonna do anything else all
that stuff I wouldn't know if I'm not
kissing your ass but if I do HP I'm
doing how you did it oh yeah cut through
nose yeah it's like in three no it looks
like if Starbucks did a comedy show
everyone dresses like they work on
Starbucks it won't pay to be there huh
yeah I hate doing comedy show there are
tables our audience trying to be famous
to attack it around you have more behind
you a lot of those comics do I think
most those comics are unknown completely
but you know what if they're doing it
great for them they're hustling but it's
not my cup of tea
yeah so inflamed everybody's outside of
the peace level keep doing shows that
keeping them alive
am i coming out with the album or a
special next year I'm gonna try
something next year people yeah that is
a couple months away next they cancelled
I'm already I'm house of cards and
orders a new black where the orange new
black is already old they should they
should have done they should have done
backstories on every one of those Oh
why's that I wanted to know more about
da Rihanna and whatever her name is I
wanted to know about more about her in
the drug deals with her mom's boyfriend
I wanted to know all that stuff they
never got into their backstories that's
all you don't care about yeah cartel
shows her taking over right now yeah man
Mexico narcos new one that guy he from
your hometown huh which one
no he's from Redlands yeah Kiki Camarena
and Kiki the fool that was who they
killed in the future lock up da was a
hotter hotel when they killed him Ryan
after that they torture that fool nobody
was touchable for that right yeah well
they got the doctor they did that and
then that's how got it so they were they
were torturing him then a doctor to keep
them alive bow tie with a torturer Wow
yeah but because of him
no fate or anyone's touchable out there
are there if I was cartel I walk around
with like an AIDS thing if I hate this I
get AIDS don't you cut me you're getting
aids to or something start biting their
butt
yeah like Jason Bourne it at their death
pill yeah on that right you're heavy
crazy though he were just have my red
shoes and go home your baby mama catches
you tap my shoes I end up at my baby's
mom sauce
what some was turn on a stretcher like
I'm coming to her like Oh Sherlock
Sherlock is you're guaranteed to get
laid dog if you oh I know I've been at
her long yeah hey I told Eddie if he
goes to Texas all the big girls will
love this
barbeque four days done I'm down hey hey
Jeter slice slice yeah ha I wonder but
you never been there but I brought him a
sandwich it was Bob I never I never you
think I don't need meat I would think oh
nice yeah yeah that will keep me sure
every look all about Christian little
stories yeah the scary ones the booklets
yeah he gave me a box of all of them
every single one and again and you know
he had those all read the gospel yeah
man super cover terrible geo how fat
that [ __ ] is that was just fat how me I
had one George how was it man how
ridiculous dark like mom well it fell
out but I was I was I was like oh yeah
the cornbread and the pastrami that's
what I had
oh that fool you know related they all
do you yeah he said he took me
everywhere we were [ __ ] onion I came
home with diabetes yeah man that the
press right what do you mean full showed
up bro to the big kids guest pots over
there nobody nobody nobody
oh just you and him it was me him and
this chick named Becky she was cool she
was a local comic their feature for the
shore their opener but all but the fools
from what's the church the church family
they came [ __ ] deep ha hey and I
ain't gonna lie I was a little groupie
they hit me up hey homie do you want to
get high I said [ __ ] yeah
hello but out there how much it was
garbage but they brought it from Buffalo
like there was fools from Buffalo
Chicago there yeah and DC in this old
Irish oh yeah he sold out every show it
is it was it was crazy dawg
they weren't had a study I don't do
Sundays yeah and they wanted to add a
third show Saturday and he was just like
real clock whatever magician yeah I
gotta be home early for mercy you can't
take time away and I was like [ __ ] yeah
we because we left at 5:00 in the
morning the next day he wasn't [ __ ]
around we were in that hour
yeah we were in a labor 9:00 o'clock dad
was there Flay out 5:30
[ __ ] we sent our drummer go pick him up
duffel sleep yeah he did yeah he slept
he eats those bubble gums any final
hangout we just after the show you don't
talk to people to a show he did this
time he did he was just like you know
what man I sold it I've never sold it
out like this yeah so he stayed took
picture we were kidding with the Chief
of Police
he's gonna see that a lot more with that
Netflix stuff oh do people were crying
this one Indian titles if they could
today we touched the feet of men we look
up to enjoy come on now gotta touch your
feet don't want to touch these peacocks
it was it was cool man
yeah it was cool dog you know how many
people showed up with photos of him a
lot like four yeah first like like when
I saw that do Marla photos okay but they
like other folks started doing them and
I all right man you you're you need you
you need help bro you're not a belieber
fired a legion of like middle-aged bull
never got I saw [ __ ] it out baba get bro
can i watch i Baba again thinking about
Willie Barcena
seaside hating his brother the whole
movie but
I read through the whole movie that for
real Haiti
oh yeah he said Murali's and the mom is
[ __ ] really like not liking him and
put him in a straight-up feel bad she
led him to that [ __ ] yeah bro call him a
flunky the only one when he won the
[ __ ] it was a contest instead of like
appreciate oh I'm so proud of you we
could use some of the money for the baby
oh I was there too bro you just want to
punch him or her [ __ ] bro hey he
throws a beer at her man I was like [ __ ]
she was pregnant through him beers
they're pregnant
oh he's a good [ __ ] actor he
somebody's he got robbed bro he should
have been nominated for Best Supporting
back I tell them we're gonna do La Samba
that bad dinner
that's bomb oh he was playing bomb
O'Reilly Richie Valens brother who
they're from Pacoima Watsonville and
Modesto bro I did some more information
well I started reading trying to find
out more because um I don't never got
noticed in the movie
Bobby wearing an actual motorcycle club
[ __ ] that vest okay the galloping
goose the galloping goose was little
Club and therefore a wide bro oh yeah
they're big bro they're not
one-percenters they were at the original
fight with in Laughlin in [ __ ] that
town where the with a big were the first
motorcycle fight started Sturgis on the
Sturgis master jail in California
I know Hollister at Hollister honest
between the [ __ ] booze fighters and
the whiskey fighters so that that uh the
motorcycle gang that barb is wearing in
the in the movie they let him wear the
actual [ __ ] vest on the president of
the motorcycle club who started it is in
the movie - he plays the bartender okay
so the movie was set in 1956 right but
the [ __ ] of the motorcycle gang was
started in 1947 so eleven
with Archie turned away by the way he's
a morality Raleigh he's Puerto Rican
isn't he no but the actor he was
actually walking about that Bob said
about it when he saw the movie he said
when I when I saw the movie I started
appreciating my Mexican heritage more
cuz I'm Bob you know and Richie badly
they grew up in an area where it wasn't
down yeah me too darling I'm Marvin
Orange
my mom too much she was like nobody
noticed but you're covered or you want
to make it yeah you weren't a ton of
speak Spanish so they whip your wife no
my parents were only talk to his pants
in the house but like my dad was a
coyote and he had two jobs so we had a
little bit of money so into the good
schools and I'm lucky homie I'm the let
I'm the fifth a six boys on my older
brothers already moved to a strong when
I got there it was okay to be a cholo
and [ __ ] seniority bro they're already
tired of a salute they'd already
disappointed now there were like good
dough like boy you were a little boy and
your brother were boys in Orange County
with a different from now weather less
Mexican little more that's cool at my
school I don't know because like the
white people never left orange they're
still there and those that were like the
majority although it's way more cuz
Santana just Santana was like you know
how there's a caravan out there those
fools had a couple mini buses stopped by
like it's flooded on the butcher school
over the light with the will of the
majority white know we were 35 white
thirty percent met skin and like
everything I was like but we never had
black guys ever good at sports that's
what sucked all the black guys we have
our just gang members let me talk to
Ruben Paul we talked about how like a
lot of the black school that Crenshaw
[ __ ] and then I think Carver High are
the black other great or lack players
Jordan downs
it won't stay them to Orange County it's
a modern-day or big address yeah and no
bus some dogs also no feed them they put
only two please
James oh yeah but then that team were
they from it sucks down yeah and then
like if that forgets injury they get no
money again but that's how it is dog so
it is your badass [ __ ] there you gonna
stop right trying to get into college
but you can hopefully get some of the
college recruiters to come see you if
you've got all that buzz about you you
know
and there's perch - those fools are
getting broken off dog high schools [ __ ]
the running back from my team he had
three thousand yards are his sophomore
year and his junior year he had three
thousand and Michigan told him do not
play your senior year and we're
guarantee you and our coach was paying
his rent and this mother he [ __ ] his
knee up and then God he took not to play
in the next year he asked David yeah
when his coach was paying the rent yeah
he was trying to go for the record and
[ __ ] boom and now for hit a sprinkler on
the field in his blood about that when
you play get a full bum in this [ __ ]
spring [ __ ] potholes
yeah you might [ __ ] the road he might
step on a gopher a rabbit that fell down
and then played that song by e-40
sprinkle me on playing army out there it
was good dog he was hey you know it's
[ __ ] up is better fly yeah took it bad
hey this fool took it so bad that he
joined our game he became a cholo that's
black bull dog
he was like cartoon from blood and blood
oh yeah for the first time he said hey
man honey I'm on the [ __ ] my Freddy
yeah it was the light-skinned black fur
dog that had a Mexican in him but no his
name is Goldie
Jamie wertham you can look him up bad
Google me he couldn't catch me he could
run on backfilled he was elusive like
goofy running dog they would have turned
him into a defensive back dog and no
homie he was too dude he was he was 6-3
like 230
he would have been neck and neck with
rocky Ishmael died his cast looked like
Tommy Chong's in each cab
[ __ ] the biggest a CL
[Laughter]
it was a lot of fun comedian that we
haven't seen a long-ass time he's in
North Carolina dog who is Tommy chicken
with a San Diego now he moved his lady
she became the president of Weight
Watchers out there that fools oh shut up
she keeps gaining weight and they give
her more weight and worked she fixed his
Jeep and he married her dog [ __ ] dog
nuts what's that word we're getting high
at house when he had a little studio I
remember that man that full shoulder his
modeling tape what do you mean modeling
taking the model he was trying to be a
model how old was he
I don't know when he first got here 30 I
guess too late but you know you see know
at least joint and he we're like a tux
and he's walking he like somebody they
made in somebody's house and he wanted
this Tommy charm foggy
jheri curl [ __ ] I remember before I was
a comedian dog I used to love Master P
and then Tommy Chunn came out and I'm
Master P remember he did a comedy
special ed Griffin was on yeah and I and
then I seen that fool at [ __ ] second
base dog we had a baggie contest and I
beat that full he was just like use a
hair no how long you been doing comedy I
ever do comedy not even yet dawg
he was cool after that the homie was
real good to me dawg you guys go way
back right we went about the walking
what do we mean a man I met him with you
like oh my cell yeah yeah yeah Velasquez
okay and he bought us Taco Bell no
Pete's
hell yeah bro in the day she's done
hey that runs done huh nobody still
around little boogers okay hey he's
still around though doesn't book you
don't work
little work with him but he Betty
co-productions done you know you know
you know why they call it Polly Cooper -
because he just gives you a bump for
pain his hair set forever huh well he
has to be like out of people name I
don't think that for lazy dog cuz he
came one time I did the chunk Chauncey
casino sure what chunk Chauncey casino
Tommy George yeah yeah how'd you cut a
dog he was in the front row and I was
she leaning I looked at him I'm like
when can I get up at your club I forgot
up and left I taking her - I'm not
trying to get robbed no he's he's he
brags about how little he used to pay
George Lopez I'm sure he brags about now
how little he used to pay you for the
day I picture $200 and everybody were so
so how the podcasts going man I was
going good about we're at 84 now 16 more
weeks the hard road episode I swear I
was gonna ask you if you could do the
hundred episode and we're throwing a
huge party it's gonna be at Ziggy smoke
shop and there's gonna be custom guys
making you a custom bong like it's gonna
be a party afterwards barbecue we can
have vegan if you want he's gonna be
there yeah he's only a dog it's gonna be
like some sick vibe and then there's
these white boy band out there all they
do is play funk music but it's white
hipsters do cover bands chronic album
last summer their dog half of bad ass
yeah right everything I did a [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ]
yes you parking on Mondays right I do it
on Monday so do it no after this we're
gonna go to the comedy store I'm gonna
do my podcast tomorrow humming I love
coming on
by the communists or I'm gonna go hang
up have we try to Bogart my way on to uh
was tonight she's hosting tonight the
old sound guy from the HR quimbo yeah
he's cool he's works at the store now
and he get these cool man I was I feel
afraid to go up well I told him years
ago I said you gotta try other rooms
outside of the ice house you can't
expand your audience type you know man
if I do he's a black guy he said if I do
black rooms like you know there's a
certain attitude you have to have like
this Def Jam attitude and I said not
everybody if you're funny they'll love
you doesn't matter and he just didn't
have the confidence in it yeah he looks
like a Paddington Bear but like yeah
he's hella cool he's gotta get over that
what's up with you doggy dog I seen you
on what's that show you're always on
where you you're when I got a shopping
market ourselves superstore there's your
money just gonna have to do another
episode probably over that's like a
reoccurring character they yeah bode
well the guy who is one of the executive
producers of the show Ruben Fleischer
who did venom okay I'm - bro no way I'm
a big carnage I thought that keeps on
giving to expire
[Laughter]
no but he got asked back for December if
they don't write him out but for now
they're using them you will see the end
of watch movie [ __ ] miraculous yeah I
forget how good she was [ __ ] bro you
know I like a savory but yeah look at
the character like gonna kill or that
[ __ ] Gina I got the [ __ ] beat
she's dude her character were like like
she's [ __ ] cold man like she didn't
give a buzz and she even called by the
auditory name ah nobody knew her name
and she cookie I think that's terrifying
advice to pull that good that [ __ ]
happens a lot yeah yeah but she was
pushing all that cash you had the
coconut menudo
there's no like to him he's like my
thought is to her ah
and then I already have my wait the
tunnel together already plan they do
drills for this [ __ ] but I she was real
hot when an end of watch when they
[ __ ] they're like spine the late they
made a call all the way to [ __ ]
Mexico for real yeah that food is funny
I don't that so much money that he's
just hiring any gang yeah like nothing
well they they found that house remember
with all the dead bodies that was crazy
I don't know why they say before what do
you mean it's more suspicious to be
burying bodies everywhere you gotta keep
them in that house nobody knows the
corns good next year but a dog you know
what's crazy about that movie is at the
end a cop gets killed
yeah and it's glorifying I was at the
movies all the trolls were like focus ad
yeah
I hear that party yeah oh I'm sorry
gonna [ __ ] you see that white guy over I
can save him I didn't they fight that
fool huh for dropping the mail that they
fight the blood or so yeah yeah take
that badge off you ain't [ __ ] and they
box in the living room dog for that his
ass beat took him to jail
you know lately the cops have been
[ __ ] cool as [ __ ] to me for some
reason that I get pulled over together
with a full pot yeah I got this carpet
ticket I dropped him off in a first yeah
how did you get it we were [ __ ] drunk
though yeah I got a car pool table about
myself dog insurance he just gave me the
carpel ticket let me go we were in Santa
Ana partying dog and then there was a
lot more party going I'm like I'm not
going over I'll see you later and he
took off I had to and 300 bucks
I ain't gonna pay me skipping Court
everything he's still saved money well
do you are nothing I said [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] 20 T's right
I bought him all the drinks that hey I
know how much we drink so it's tacos job
bro nice meal taco shop right now it's
on HBO demand it's they're gonna
probably put it in red box and it's at
some Walmart's and some targets and
actually they're changing the cover to
put it in red box you remember the old
pollster cover yeah die one that looks
vintage they're gonna go with that and
you know doc working on stuff and
hopefully we'll see what happens what's
up we'll shut up to a fool from San
Diego frog belly was like a pudding
Benji Benji Benji Garcia Benji Garcia
and Louis something and then another guy
named
well hey this better stand-up comedy I
mean I wouldn't stop walking
nervous bro I was like getting out like
that you brought you know that bud you
gave him for your left yeah I smoked it
in a backward and then do nothing to me
bro that's how nervous I was
yeah well sometimes your bro what's it
like doing common in the beginning again
oh man I thought I couldn't get high
that backwards didn't do nothing for me
but after I killed in Spanish for a
little pain or smoked half
came down yeah man but I was up well I
had to follow this that funny-ass
argentinian guy when I was on stage then
Argentinian guy I'll say your name name
is Jack something he from Tijuana
Jack Jack and Argentinian T yeah and
they had a little room whatever right
and that's what I saw that full
recording me when I was killing hey did
you cheat the way yeah we practicing my
[ __ ] yeah man it was Jackie from TJ
that's his name Jack Jack Alex Jack
paddocks Argentina
you were funny though funny bro but it
was good cuz the floor was like stand up
you know yeah don't steal from you I got
25 minutes brother another 35 and we'll
do our I was going going back November
24 he started Eve our row with you yeah
you're in the show November 24th I think
it's a Saturday Saturday after
Thanksgiving drive over then come back
we're coming back I think into town that
morning I don't know Spanish they were
Jack Mencia we will get you the car bits
of comedy palace yeah like that [ __ ] I
know I'm trying to get him yeah we went
to the green room and that the the
comedian some documentary of Cavaliers
play right and then others by start to
media are talking to me in Spanish
okay I think these are lower lows Jesus
colobus here they call it busienss
talking and there was passed away with
one oil everything and they call
Monsieur say that he does so jokes yeah
we're talking about here is that I don't
know time documentary and it's called
yeah good joke I take it yeah he goes
I'm like Puff Daddy every mix - yeah
yeah
look who's watching a show that this is
well up or cool this is
yeah yeah I'll find it right now if you
have time but the new Mencia in Mexican
comedy or Spanish comedies of Franco
Escamilla right yeah or he used to steal
to the door I don't know if he is but in
the past he has stuff in one of them or
two before stopped or got any retracted
saying you just [ __ ] around though the
thing he was probably on a curse you
know I remember liar liar they did him
to tell you this pin is blue he ain't
the only one guilty that my what's up
fool Ruben Ruben
towbar Omar Gonzalez are 14 14 Jabir
Meza Greg Reilly say [ __ ]
showing up for real I come 6 6 1 what's
up homie germ dosed what up dog liar
liar though before love movies that's
movie I saw what I went to old Scotch
copycat last night remember copycat with
Sigourney Weaver no it's a wherever
she studies serial killers and she puts
away this bomb answer a killer there
Jessie girl huh
no I know this is different she puts
away this badass drug deal I mean that
serial killer and he has a cult so he
gets this other guy to start like being
a badass here a killer to bring her out
of retirement
[Laughter]
yeah yeah man would you go hooked on
that [ __ ] boy you can see who he is
he's nice southern hospitality like you
know he promotes like all kind of ship
but he charged them he's a greaser and I
said you know what's her money look at
George's watch yeah we know it's big dog
oh yeah I do bumps off of any easy
access it opens up my trailer to a scale
now it reminds me who owes me money to
Michael Jackson were so cool best truck
in our lair forgive bro everything you
give us five bucks we don't get it by
the way beautiful
thanks comedy [ __ ] Alex are that's
Alex are drunk too you give it away
buddy right now huh are you a little
[ __ ] ever that one uncle I'll just show
up and before I say hello just throw
money in the air make me dog
like I did that because that my uncle my
dad was that uncle he will do that he'd
be right ice cubes yeah cuz like my dad
was the one with the good ass jobs all
my cousins with free Lord awful was like
do you good just to piss prisons my mom
and my dad would give him all our shitty
pie you guys do that [ __ ] too man
yeah we pay Mexico we got poor and poor
mother yeah ain't no money no good time
we're not invited a one-foot pasola dog
yeah they're gonna put up seven plates
now yeah you know what's left with us is
my dad you're broke now my dad passed
away he passed away for my mum my dad
passed away I did that show a while
Caillou remember I showed up in a suit
yeah smoke the blunt but uh he let
everybody borrow money and they wouldn't
pay us like that too bro
yeah then it was just like [ __ ] God
we're not friends with no boys are not
the only money I lost friends like that
yeah [ __ ] it is what it is but
they'll show up at least those hard when
they showed up and me I wasn't crying -
loudest at the funeral those fools are
yeah it's weird dog cuz my dad was a
player so he had family other places
[Laughter]
pepper looking at us going why are these
[ __ ] get to carry the the coffin is
[ __ ] because we pay for the funeral
[ __ ] so you meant like yeah I mean I
love the ones that I know I love but the
ones I didn't know I was kind of like
that [ __ ] fool looks like me
[Laughter]
yeah we have a couple of November 13th
second thing that's good okay I have
nothing I have a lot of chores you know
that's all I do is joy go to order
orders on full Hey this Friday we're
gonna be at a Charlie's tattoo shop in
San Tong up giving up this new gear
right here Orange County by big sleeps
it's gonna be this Saturday November
10th at Charlie's tattoo big sleeps
gonna be there I'll be there and
afterwards we're going to the block
party at the ice cube Mexico now the
block parties will be cracking dog
Santana's hey Nana
I'll get stamped to watch this show I'm
gonna see it's the waters dog Judy as
well I can't be cocaine when she goes on
stage
what's up with her - Joe Coco Diaz I
know we're talking about two weeks ago
that me and Lisa were pitching our
shoulder ABC CBS they all give it a big
I know we're gonna move we're gonna
pitch or show the cable whoever says
yeah well [ __ ] all that man
has he talked about sometimes the body
right Jody I told you right they show
that picked up III don't know I don't
want to say that that you're talking but
he show you yeah I don't want to say
metal he tell you no he didn't tell me
about it
yeah we got picked up Jody show got
picked up and I picked up two Arab TV I
got picked up for a pilot okay and
that's it okay yeah any percenter bring
me in this we didn't know shots with
Kern County Kern County that's over
there
I bet a prisoner or a big no-no that's
Bakersfield the hardcore meth white boy
from there that looks like x-files and X
Games were so fool hit me up man are
being if you live in now if you want to
go to Buffalo I'll hook you up with
tickets a pair of tickets if you wanna
go to Toledo I'll hook you up to man
that's it don't have nothing else Late
Late